What's up guys, my name Is Colin McNeil for theScore esports.
You know, there’s a reason they call Faker
the Unkillable Demon King.
This guy goes beyond titles like  “series MVP” or even “world champion.” This guy
is the League of Legends G.O.A.T.
From his incredible outplays to his surgical team
fighting skills, here are the best plays
from Faker's competitive League of Legends career.
During the 2016 World Championship semifinals,
the ROX Tigers took SKT to a climactic game
5.
While they fell behind early, Gorilla, Smeb,
and Peanut looked like they were going to
catch the star mid laner out in top lane.
With an incredible dodge on Peanut’s cocoon
and only using his Ghost summoner spell,
Faker manages to get away, denying ROX the
kill on the way to his third World’s title.
(Casting)
As one of the world's most dominant laners,
Faker often finds the slimmest openings to
solo kill his lane opponents.
KT’s Nagne was trapped under the turret
by Faker’s Riven and with Wolf coming out
of the jungle Faker had all the support he was going to need.
After a Flash to counter Nagne’s own and
an incredible sidestep to dodge the Cassiopeia
ult, Faker managed to walk out with a kill.
(Casting)
After getting caught by the cocoon from KT’s
Score and getting dropped to less than a quarter
health, Faker landed a defensive ultimate
to push out Hachani’s Alistar.
After turning back onto Score, Faker used
his Zhonya’s Hourglass to give his team
time to enter the fight.
With a numbers advantage, Faker and SKT managed
to turn the tide.
(Casting)
In another match against Korean rivals KT Rolster, the
two teams were locked in a back-and-forth teamfight in the Baron side river.
That is, until Faker blew the fight wide open.
Catching an already weak Nagne and Arrow
with his Syndra ultimate, Faker landed his E
and Q on both players, killing Nagne before
finishing off Arrow with an auto attack.
(Casting)
At the 2014 All-Star Paris tournament, SKT
found themselves up against Fnatic.
With two players down for SKT, Fnatic decided
it was time to push Baron.
Faker dove into the Baron pit, managing to
find a quick kill onto the enemy jungler before
jumping back across the wall.
With the rest of SKT there to support him,
Faker jumped back in and finished off both
the Baron and xPeke to win the fight.
(Casting)
During their first Worlds 2017 group stage
match, SKT faced off against Cloud9.
After a pretty passive nine minutes, Contractz
decided that it was time to put the pressure
on Faker.
But you just don’t do that to the Unkillable
Demon King.
Landing a quick ultimate and a perfectly timed
Flash under his own tower, Faker managed to
not only get away, but find a kill on Contractz.
(Casting)
With Faker’s dominant lane presence in this
2016 Summer Split matchup against CJ Entus,
SKT had already taken two of the middle lane
towers.
With only the inhibitor turret left, three
players attempted to hold off the siege from
SKT, but Faker had other plans.
(Casting)
Down 12 kills to one and facing a 4v5 situation
with KT’s fresh Baron buff, Faker managed
to land an incredible shockwave with Oriana,
getting a triple kill and helping SKT secure
the ace.
(Casting)
SKT found themselves behind the eight ball early
against EDward Gaming in their second group stage game
at Worlds 2017.
With Baron and dragon about to spawn, EDG
were grouped up in the mid lane.
That’s when SKT initiated an explosive teamfight.
Faker landed his shockwave on four of EDG’s
players, killing Meiko.
In the end SKT managed to kill four players and
regain control of the game for their second
group stage win.
(Casting)
Our number one entry on this list is one of
the best known and most viewed plays in League
of Legends history.
Faker’s Zed outplay against Ryu is arguably
the moment that catapulted him to international
fame.
Now a lot has been said about this incredible
play over the years, so let’s let Faker’s near superhuman
reactions speak for themselves.
(Casting)
Kind of humbles you to see play at that level
doesn’t it?
Now it's got to be said, with a player as legendary as Faker is, there were a ton of awesome plays to choose from.
And if you think we missed one on our list, let us know in the comments section below.